heroes it's an old-fashioned notion a  visionary from genius ensuring freedom  around the globe symbol to the nation  a hero to the world the beautiful  shining out  across the stars  I look around the bus you know I see a  bunch of a-holes possibility  you think you know how the world works  the wound  is changing  we  heroes  our very strength  [Music]  invites challenging  Challenge insights culture  culture  Brie's catastrophe  the thing isn't beautiful because it  lasts  we're in the anger  before we're done  we still have one promise to keep  you can't protect the Earth it can be  damn sure we'll avenge it  whatever it takes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]